So first we have to understand some basic physiology of your immune system
So your immune system is formulated, anybody know where your immune system is at your body?
Small intestine
What?
Hi
The bones
Really your immune system is everywhere, okay?
Your immune cells are circulating through your blood and your immune cells do one thing
and one thing well, they kill things.
So you have T cells that are circulating around your body and all these are different stages of development
and they're macrophages, they're white blood cells, they're specifically to go around looking for something to kill.
So as we talk about to make it simple, you have really two pieces of your immune response.
You have what's called your immediate response or what we could call your TH-1 response and you have your TH-2 response.
And your TH-1 response, if you can think of it like a cartoon, they are the Marine Corps going around with machine guns looking for something to kill.
That's what's going to keep you from getting sick is a healthy TH-1 response.
So your TH-1 response is your immediate response.
So if I come in this room and you breathe a virus on me, that virus goes into my body through my lungs and enters into my bloodstream
and if it's at a great enough concentration, I am going to fire my immune system, it's going to fire a TH-1 response.
So my TH-1 cells stimulate more production, it releases more TH-1 cells.
They go down, they find that virus and they kill that virus and then that TH-1 response drops back down.
And so I have this little blip of a TH-1 response if we want to think of it that way.
And then it kills the virus and it goes back into balance and I'd ever do what I was sick.
Now this happens to us on a daily basis, many times a day, quite often.
So we're exposed to some pathogen and that our body kills that pathogen and I'd never got sick.
Well I didn't get sick, everybody else was sick of the room and I'd never got sick.
You had a healthy TH-1 response and it was strong enough to kill that virus and your body went back into balance.
So normally a person, this immune system, this immune response needs to be balanced all the time but it's never balanced all the time.
It is always just coming back to equilibrium.
So I have an exposure to a pathogen, it fires a TH-1 response, it kills it, it brings back into balance.
So let's say I'm exposed to a really bad pathogen like some influenza or something like that.
So I fire a TH-1 response, it's not able to kill it, eight hours later it's continuing to fire a TH-1 response, continuing to fire a TH-1 response.
That's what I'm not feeling really good, I think I got a fever, I don't really feel so hot.
The light's sweaty, you know I look okay?
And I go home and I take a nap, I go to bed and that TH-1 response then is unable to kill it within 24 hours.
Then what your body does is it shuts down the TH-1 response and it fires this TH-2 response.
Now the TH-2 side of your immune system is responsible mainly for creating antibodies.
Now whatever it is that the TH-1 response fired against, whatever pathogen that was, and it's supposed to only fire against some livid organism like a virus, bacteria, parasite, fungus, mold, Lyme disease, something like that.
It fired a response against it and it wasn't, if it wasn't able to kill it, that's when the TH-1 response will be suppressed in the TH-2 response fires.
Stay with me because it's really important when you're dealing with taking care of people with these issues.
Now the TH-2 response fires, think of them pictorially as the CIA or the FBI.
They're not going to really kill anything but they're going to go in there and they're going to find whatever pathogen the TH-1 response fired against and they're going to tag it.
So they're actually creating antibodies that fit right around that but think of it as they're going to mark it with a tag.
There's the virus, we're going to mark it with some fluorescent tape and that's what the TH-2 response does.
And then within about 24 hours that suppresses and I fire another TH-1 response.
And now the Marine Corps with the machine guns can now find the enemy and it kills it.
So now I was sick for a couple of days but now I feel a lot better, I don't know what I had.
I was in bad eye and I drank a bunch of chicken soup and took some vitamin C and I feel great.
Well you fired a TH-1 and a TH-2 response and a TH-1 response and you wound the battle and now you're better.
That's really what happened from an immunological perspective.